dans toute histoire
il y à ce qui est visible
et ce qui est caché
c'est d'autant plus vrai quand il s'agit
d'histoires de guerre
les américains les canadiens et les
britanniques débarqueront sur la côte
sud de la sicile
n'importe quel imbécile se doutera que
ce sera la sicile iter devra croire que
nous tenterons d'envahir la cresse nous
allons devoir lui montrer des preuves
de fausses preuves bien sûr que diriez
vous de commencer par le plus simple en
allant nous trouver un cadavre
ou comme un astre
nom d'un chien alors puis ce fut gerre
de trouver un visage vivant voici mon
ami le sergent rogers diop a dit il m'a
dit que vous vouliez vous entretenir
avec moi
nous commencerons à lui donner un vrai
nom pour que les allemands qui
vérifieront les listes et du mal à
l'identifier le major william arte
il nous faut une histoire d'amour
vous auriez besoin de mon aide c'est une
opération de grande ampleur l'opération
cheval de troie nous l'avons renommée ce
sera moins explicite
opération chair à pâté
mettant ainsi lé dans la pliure s'il
n'est plus là quand nous récupérons la
lettre cela signifiera qu'elle a été lu
[Musique]
vont faire circuler les faux documents
rapidement avec le concours précieux de
deux agents allemands que se
passera-t-il s'il entre au cfaa suite à
un séjour prolongé dans l'océan il
faudra une encre résistante à l'eau il
faut avoir prévu de se noyer pour écrire
avec ce type d'encre exact
viser vos ressources lancé l'opération
au plus vite
le major martin
pour le succès de notre mission
pour ceux qui sont chers à nos cars
les dés sont jetés
il est impossible de reculer